si aquí a las puertas de la corte como
podéis ver de momento no hay muchos
manifestantes parece que esa
convocatoria que hizo Donald Trump el
sábado a través de su propia red social
convocando a la gente a manifestarse hoy
martes por su inmediata detención parece
que no ha tenido mucho poder sí que
vemos aquí alguna protesta Muchos medios
de comunicación Eso sí y muy pendientes
de ver qué ocurre con ese gran Jurado
Que no está tan claro que hoy vaya a
tomar esa decisión Porque primero porque
ayer la declaración del último testigo
terminó bastante tarde Así que es muy
probable que ayer no hicieran esa
votación acerca de si acusaban a Trump o
no y segundo porque este gran Jurado
compuesto por 23 personas y para que
salga adelante cualquier decisión tiene
que estar apoyada secundada por 12 de
ellas solamente se reúne el lunes
miércoles y viernes además hay rumores
algunas televisiones locales del país
apuntan a que mañana miércoles se podría
escuchar a otro testigo por lo que
tendríamos que seguir esperando a que
tomasen esa decisión por parte del
equipo de gal de Donald Trump ya han
dicho que de momento Donald de momento
ellos me han recibido ninguna
convocatoria que en caso de que Donald
Trump fuese acusado y tenga que
personarse aquí lo va a hacer de manera
voluntaria pero no creen que vaya a
suceder esta semana ni una convocatoria
ni unas declaraciones ni un arresto no
creen que vaya a suceder de manera tan
inminente como al parecer anunció el
expresidente Donald Trump en su cuenta
de red social